فاذا نقلا عن حركه حماس نزف الشهيد
القسامي المعتز بالله الخواجه نزف عفوا
الشهيد القسامي المعتز بالله الخواجه
ونبارك عمليته البطوليه ونتوعد الاحتلال
المجرم بالمزيد اذا حركه حماس تتبنى هذه
العمليه وتقول بانه شهيد من كتائب القسام
وهو المعتز بالله خواجه
اذا ووفق هيئه البث الاسرائيليه فان منفذ
عمليه الابيب شاب عمره 23 عاما من بلده
عليم شمال غرب رام الله وقد افاد مراسل
الجزيره ان قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت البلده
وهي تشتبه بان منفذ الهجوم من سكانها هيئه
البث الاسرائيليه قالت ايضا ان رئيس
الحكومه باليمين نتنياهو يبحث تقديم موعد
عودته من روما في اعقاب عمليه اطلاق
الناره وصفها بعمليه صعبه
وارهابيه ايضا وايضا قال ان هدف المعارضه
ان تتدهور الاوضاع الى الفوضى واجراء
انتخابات سادسه اما رئيس بلديه تل ابيب
قال ان عمليه اطلاق النار وسط المدينه
خلفيتها قوميه وطالب الاسرائيليين بوقف
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه فورا عقب هذه العمليه